ah
sigue la conmoción en haití después del
asesinato del presidente joven él moix a
manos de hombres armados que asaltaron
su residencia cuatro sospechosos
murieron en enfrentamientos con la
policía y dos más están detenidos mira
la nación se encuentra en estado de
sitio
el primer ministro japonés yoshihiro
declaró formalmente el estado de
emergencia sanitaria en tokio a partir
del 12 de julio y hasta el próximo 22 de
agosto esto cuando faltan apenas dos
semanas para la inauguración de los
juegos olímpicos 2020 la capital
japonesa reporta un nuevo incremento en
los contagios por kobe 19
a partir de la medianoche las
operaciones de búsqueda y rescate en
south side miami llegaron a su fin y
dieron paso a la recuperación de cuerpos
atrapados bajo los escombros del
edificio de 12 pisos que se desplomó el
pasado 24 de junio las autoridades
confirmaron que ya no hay posibilidades
de encontrar sobrevivientes
[Música]
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y del mundo aquí en paradas 24 yo
soy liliana valencia iniciamos en la
tira nación caribeña sigue conmocionada
por el asesinato del presidente joven el
mois quién fue abaleado en su residencia
privada en la madrugada de martes a
miércoles la policía haitiana confirmó
la baja de cuatro sospechosos de haber
participado en el magnicidio mientras
otros dos presuntos implicados están
bajo custodia de las autoridades
organismos internacionales expresaron su
preocupación por la preservación de la
democracia en el país donde fue
declarado el estado de sitio por 15 días
dándole más poder al ejecutivo para
atender la típica situación que
atraviesa el consejo de seguridad de la
onu se reunirá este jueves para abordar
la situación del país
afirmaron ser de la dea la agencia
antidrogas de eeuu pero no lo eran
mataron al presidente la mayoría hablaba
español y algunos hablaban inglés
estamos recopilando información y
sabemos que algunos de ellos aún
se encuentran en el país 0 y lo somos
demos tilden de construir entre tanto la
ciudadanía haitiana pide justicia e
investigaciones que esclarezcan los
hechos que acabaron con la vida del
mandatario y que le causaron heridas a
la primera dama martín moody's quien fue
llevada hacia miami para recibir
atención médica y resguardar su
seguridad
y simplemente dicen que son mercenarios
si son mercenarios de dónde vienen qué
país los envió
eso no tiene sentido realmente quiero
saber qué pasó arriba odiamos cambiamos
de información porque japón declaró
nuevo estado de emergencia en tokio que
coincidirá con los juegos olímpicos 2020
el primer ministro yoshihiko
implementará la medida a partir del 12
de julio cuando faltan sólo dos semanas
para la inauguración del certamen
deportivo
la decisión se extenderá hasta el 22 de
agosto la nueva declaración de
emergencia a la cuarta para tokio podría
afectar a la asistencia de público en
las sedes deportivas olímpicas de la
capital y sus alrededores la medida
pretende frenar el aumento de casos de
ccoo y 19 justo cuando la capital
japonesa reporta una cifra diaria de 896
contagios acercándose a los máximos
alcanzados por última vez a mediados de
mayo
aunque el número de pacientes gravemente
enfermos y las tasas de ocupación de
camas hospitalarias se han mantenido en
el nivel bajo se debe tener en cuenta el
impacto de las cepas
debemos fortalecer las contramedidas
para evitar que las infecciones se
propaguen al resto del país de 9 dada la
situación
emitiremos un estado de emergencia para
tokio y lo ampliaremos en okinawa hasta
el 22 de agosto y deva en los tributos 2
vamos con noticias del continente
africano porque el ex presidente de
sudáfrica jacob zuma se entregó a la
policía este miércoles tras ser
sentenciado a 15 meses de prisión por
desacato al tribunal
la condena se había dictaminado desde el
pasado 29 de junio pero el ex mandatario
había solicitado no ser enviado a
prisión argumentando su avanzada edad
problemas de salud y la pandemia de kobe
19 la entrega es considerada como la
culminación de un escándalo de
corrupción en medio del cual suma habría
favorecido a empresarios sudafricanos
durante sus nueve años de gobierno
la comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos cdh constató que la respuesta
del estado colombiano a las protestas
sociales que comenzaron el pasado 28 de
abril se caracterizó por el uso excesivo
y desproporcionado de la fuerza
incluyendo la fuerza letal así lo
determina el informe presentado este
miércoles sobre la visita que el
organismo hizo en junio al país para
revisar numerosas denuncias de violencia
policial y civil el gobierno del
presidente iván duque rechazó las
conclusiones del informe
tras su visita a colombia del 8 al 10 de
junio la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos emitió sus
observaciones tras más de dos meses de
paro nacional conclusiones que no dejan
bien parado al gobierno de iván duque la
comisión constató que de manera
reiterada en diversas regiones del país
la respuesta del estado se caracterizó
por el uso excesivo desproporcionado la
fuerza en muchos casos la actuación
incluyó la fuerza letal ante este
panorama la cdh entregó 41
recomendaciones al estado la principal
separar a la policía y a su escuadrón
móvil antidisturbios esmad del
ministerio de defensa también el
organismo recomendó que los bloqueos los
cuales la cdh llama cortes de ruta no
pueden ser prohibidos de manera
generalizada una afirmación que va en
contra del discurso del estado
colombiano quien afirma que los bloqueos
son un delito
puede
recomendarle a un país ser tolerante con
actos de criminalidad pero los actos de
vandalismo los actos de terrorismo
urbano de baja intensidad los bloqueos
que atentan contra los derechos de los
ciudadanos están siendo enfrentados con
la constitución y la ley la cdh anunció
finalmente la instalación de un
mecanismo especial de seguimiento en
materia de derechos humanos para
colombia' algo a lo que la
vicepresidenta marta lucía ramírez se
opuso al considerar lo innecesario pues
calificó de sólida la institucionalidad
colombiana
la comisión condenó por otra parte la
infiltración de grupos vandálicos que
ocasionaron grandes pérdidas económicas
ataques e incendios a instalaciones del
estado bloqueos viales que causaron
desabastecimiento de alimentos medicinas
y combustible además de la muerte de dos
bebés ocurridas por falta de atención
médica
las autoridades de miami dade
confirmaron que no hay ninguna
posibilidad de encontrar sobrevivientes
bajo los escombros del edificio
residencial que colapsó el pasado 24 de
junio en shorts al florida en eeuu así
lo indicaron autoridades estas dos
semanas de operativos de búsqueda y
rescate que a la medianoche dieron paso
a la recuperación de víctimas fatales ya
son 54 los cuerpos encontrados y 86
personas siguen bajo los escombros
14 días después del derrumbe la
'operación rescate' llega a su fin a
partir de las 12 de la noche de este
miércoles la misión pasó a ser una de
solo recuperación
así lo informó daniela levin cava la
alcaldesa del condado de miami dade
con profunda tristeza les comparto que
tomamos la extremadamente difícil
decisión de hacer la transición de la
operación de búsqueda y rescate a la
operación de recuperaciones en prisión
sí
gracias a los esfuerzos de hasta 200
rescatistas 18 restos humanos más fueron
hallados en los escombros del edificio
el miércoles hasta el momento el saldo
del derrumbe es de 54 víctimas mortales
y 86 desaparecidos y aunque se han
utilizado todas las estrategias posibles
y todas las tecnologías disponibles las
autoridades consideran que existen cero
posibilidades de encontrar
sobrevivientes pero algunos mantienen la
fe
el anuncio de hoy llega como resultado
de un consenso entre los más cercanos de
los esfuerzos de rescate de que la
posibilidad de que alguien todavía esté
vivo es casi nula probablemente tengan
razón pero al final dios todavía está a
cargo y aunque parece que no hay
posibilidad de encontrar vida entre los
escombros todavía es posible un milagro
este o pasó
aún se desconocen los motivos que
llevaron al repentino colapso parcial de
sampling towers out pero un informe de
ingeniería que data de 2018 advertía ya
de graves daños estructurales el resto
de la edificación fue demolida de manera
controlada para dar mejor acceso a las
ruinas y ante el temor de los posibles
estragos de la tormenta tropical elsa el
compromiso ahora está en identificar a
las víctimas y ayudar a los familiares
de los fallecidos a darle un cierre a la
tragedia
así finalizamos este informativo pero
también los invitamos a visitar nuestra
página web tras 24 puntos para ampliar
la información de américa latina y el
mundo en cuatro idiomas quédense con
nosotros nos vemos más adelante
[Música]